Whilst this may seem very simple and honestly I'm assuming that almost all of
you understand this,
but I'm still going to say anyway because it's important, there was recently a
member who passed
his prop firm account, got to a payout and then was asked to perform an action
that implied that
he understood his risk because I think his trading was a little bit erratic. He
was asked by the
risk department of this prop firm to take an action to show that he understood
risk and he
actually failed to do so which resulted in him losing the account. So as much
as you obviously
probably already understand position sizing, it's really important this episode
. So this is going
to be specifically about forex and CFDs, so we're going to be looking at lot
sizes. Position sizing
when you're entering a trade, you'll be asked how many lots that you're willing
to place on this
trade. Your lots are actually basically your units of risk. Now whilst many of
you probably just use
a standard calculator, like I do myself, you can use something like, you know,
baby pips which gives
you a digitized calculator, you just enter your details and it will give you
how many lots to
place on that position. You can also use something like a magic keys that's
already integrated and
can automate a lot of that decision-making process to make sure that your risk
is on point which is
what I recommend to do mostly to be honest with you. What you need to
understand is how to actually
determine your lot size. And the way that you do that is by your account
balance times risk.
So if your account balance was let's say $200,000 times your risk, I obviously
recommend everyone
doesn't really go over 1% risk per trade unless you're trading a personal
account. Even then 2%
it is aggressive but I don't think it's too bad on a personal account. You have
to also think like
if you have a max drawdown of 10% on a prop firm, your 1% risk isn't actually 1
%. It's actually 10%
because you only have 10% of that account. So many people think okay I have a $
200,000
prop firm account really you only have $20,000 of actual firepower because if
you go below that $20,000
drawdown it's game over for you. So when you're risking 1%, you're actually
risking 10% of your
total available capital. So 1% is very aggressive on a prop firm but I think it
definitely makes
sense to use 1% in the challenge phase as well. Your account balance times risk
divided by the
stop loss in PIPs and then the actual PIP value per lot of that pair that's why
ask you for your
currency pair. So your dollar will have a risk value per lot and then you type
that in. So let's
say you have a 200k account, your risk percentage is 1% and let's say your stop
loss is 10 PIPs right
just for easy math sake. Well your lots will be 20. So it's account balance
times risk divided by
stop loss in PIPs times the actual PIP value of that pair. That's going to give
you your lot size.
Now here's the problem. The person was tasked with I think it was if I remember
correctly,
sub the along the lines of place a trade for X amounts of lots representing a
certain percentage
amount. So automatically what that guy is for is okay he just wants me to place
a trade on
five lots to show that I know how to place lots right and so he's placed five
lots but he hasn't
taken a moment to think about where his stop losses and where his entry is
because that PIP range
is going to indicate how much risk that five lots make up. If you've got a 50 P
IP stop loss
that five lots is going to be 10 times larger than if you have a five PIP stop
loss. The same amount
of lots equal 10 times the amount of risk. That's why I'm ultimately creating
this video is because
of course all of you understand how to use a lot size calculator for example.
But if you pass a
prop firm account and they're going to ask you hey can you demonstrate this
honestly you could just
ask Google or check tip zero just run it through a calculator but you want to
be understanding
on the call with you as well because you get a call from the risk department of
some of these
prop firms. So you want to understand account balance risk percentage stop loss
in PIPs
current sphere. So for example if he said to me hey I need you to risk for me
five lots representing
1% I can't just go play to five lots I have to make those five lots equal 1% so
I need to
look at this and I need to understand okay well I've got 200k my risk
percentage that he wants
to put on his is 1% I need to make sure that the stop size from entry to yeah
stop loss point is
the amount of PIPs that would make sense to give me the lots that equal to 1%
if he wanted
five lots 1% risk then I need to make sure that my PIP size is going to be 40
so that when I
place that trade I'm placing it with a 40 PIP stop loss and five lots that's
going to open 1%
of risk if my account balance was $200,000. So you need to understand just the
actual calculation
formula at least so it's your account balance times your risk divided by your
stop loss in PIPs
times your value per PIP of what it instrument is you're trading the obvious
easiest way to do
that is just to use these position size calculators or magic keys pretty much
what I already explained
but yeah I just wanted to make that because it's super important to make sure
that you're always
consistent with your risk and not just placing random lot sizes on your
accounts and stuff because
it will flag problems if you're just putting in ideas of what risk is just
follow the process
and make sure you're actually doing things correctly I know that sometimes when
a trade starts moving
you want to get in fast if you need faster execution speeds then look at
something like
a magic keys instead of just trying to erratically place trades on meta trader
and then trying to make
them make sense because it will save you a lot of hassle but also save your
data you don't want
your data to be skewed you want to become obsessed and you'll hear me say this
a million times
throughout this program but you want to become obsessed with process and you
want to become borderline
psychopath on your attention to detail with your processing of data forget
about the amount of
money you make you want to become obsessed with how well you're able to follow
the process and
do the stuff that you know that you're able to do and then look at the data and
refine your
action space and the data that's what you want to become obsessed over if you
become obsessed over
that the money will literally just come as a byproduct of your obsession over
mastering the
process when you just focus on the outcome and you don't put enough attention
on the on the process
the process gets skewed and therefore your outcome gets skewed so it's always
process focused because
it's the process the actions that you take that determine the outcomes if you
just focus on the
outcomes and not the actions to get the outcomes you will make a mess so yeah
hopefully that helps